let's talk about Nadeau he's taken out a
pretty unusual position for someone in
either party to say US contributes too
much and maybe as president he would
look at the fundamental purpose of NATO
and maybe there isn't one
what is the role what would the role of
NATO be in a Ted Cruz administration
it's a current role or something
different well look it you are right
that the Donald Trump's foreign policy
is bizarre and it is he's got very
little understanding of foreign policy
and what he does know is wrong what he
has been advocating his weakness is
withdraw from the world is isolationism
so with respect to Israel for example he
says he will be neutral between Israel
and the Palestinians and with respect to
NATO just two days ago he advocated
essentially withdrawing from NATO now
that is a terrible idea and it was
striking that the day after he called
for that we saw a tragic terrorist
attack in Brussels where NATO is
headquarter we shouldn't be withdrawing
from Europe we shouldn't be abandoning
our allies we should be strengthening
our alliance with Europe strengthening
our alliance with Israel and if Donald
Trump had his way if America did
withdraw from NATO would hand a massive
victory to Putin a massive victory to
Isis and the idea that Donald Trump
would want the presidency to begin with
a pre-emptive surrender turning tail and
running that that is a sign of weakness
and it is striking that that Donald's
foreign policies to the left of Barack
Obama and Hillary Clinton they're not
arguing for withdrawing from NATO and
yet yet yet Donald seems unable to
distinguish our friends from our enemies
and that's a very dangerous approach